I've held the title of data scientist at
a number of different companies now and
at every single one of them the nature
of my job has been completely different
so in this video it's story time cuz I'm
going to tell you all about my previous
jobs I'm Richard and this is Richard on
data so there's all kinds of reasons for
jobs to be significantly different from
one another things like industry size
and maturity of the company the
company's leadership there's tons of
other reasons so if you're trying to
break into data science I thought a
video like this might be pretty
instructive cuz you'll get a feel for
the differences and the types of jobs
out there maybe more of a feel for the
kind of job you're interested in and
some kind of sense about what the
day-to-day of a job might look like
before I get into that subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and also
take just half a second to smash the
like button cuz it really does help me
with the YouTube algorithm all right so
we're going to go all the way to the
beginning here just to lay some
foundation so when I got done with
college I immediately kept going to get
my masters the big idea for that being I
wanted to just get all my schooling done
at once I didn't want to just be in
school and then start making money and
then have to stop making money I just
wanted to do it all at once but during
all of that time doing my Master's I
worked as a graduate student instructor
or what's commonly known as a TA that's
an experience that I wish more people
could get and if you ever get that
opportunity then I recommend taking it
and the reason is because there's to
saying that there's no better way to
retain and to remember things than to
teach them but through a previous
internship that I had had as well as
through some connections in my
department I was able to get some early
project experience as well one of those
was research on a Botanical project so
essentially there was a research
question and I was consulted to perform
statistical review and suggestion of
other methods then later I would get a
summer engagement with a small education
startup so there was a big big
stakeholder there who was interested in
the factors that were predictive of
students failing their first class exam
and then lastly in a Capstone class I
was in a team that got connected with
the surgical Collective and their goal
was essentially to control for a variety
of variables most notably the type of
procedure and the sickness of the
patients they wanted to understand which
of their doctors were the best
performers and the worst performers so
by this point you might be thinking okay
Richard well why are you telling me all
these things that happened before you
were done with school well these
opportunities were highly valuable in
their own right I would say the thing
they caus me to grossly underestimate
was how complicated and messy data is in
the real world for one thing these data
sets would often have a lot of features
and variables in them but they were at
least reasonably well formatted and tidy
so it's really easy to look at these and
then get somewhat naive about how
complicated data is when it's generated
by by real world business processes now
when I was applying for jobs right
before I wrapped up my Master's I was
particularly interested in Consulting
companies and part of that was because I
was always pretty fascinated with the
idea of traveling for work but I also
like getting as engaged as possible with
real human stakeholders so my first job
when I got done was in a small healthc
care consulting company that was located
right in my hometown and when I say
small I literally mean it had fewer than
50 employees so honestly you couldn't
have really crafted a more perfect
position for me just getting done with
all of my school now I really do
recommend thinking about what kind of
industry you're the most interested in
and for me that's always been Healthcare
now the company was in startup territory
and it had major Financial ups and downs
but it was an absolute Blast from
beginning to end two of the projects I
was put on were travel projects with
existing clients so there were periods
where every other week I would be flying
to one of the two coasts so that
lifestyle is definitely not for everyone
especially if you're married and have
kids but at the time I loved it it was
perfect now technically going in I knew
SQL even though I had never taken a
formal college class on it but I got
thrust in the deep end with that really
quickly there were data sets with tens
of millions of rows columns with
horribly formatted text Data features
where you had absolutely no idea what
anything meant unless you asked somebody
you name it now one interesting thing
about the analytics team that we had was
there wasn't exactly standards put in
place for what technologies to use the
data sets were stored in SQL databases
so obviously SQL was a big Cornerstone
for what we were doing but after that
point there were some people wrapping
analysis up in Excel some people were
using R for everything there were some
projects where it was pretty much all R
based not as much Sequel and we would
share analysis not books back and forth
by pushing and pulling from GitHub it
was kind of all over the place the
emphasis was more on delivering value to
the clients and it's just whatever tool
that you're most comfortable with or
will allow you to do that best just use
that and I remember one project was a
little slow so I caught myself thinking
okay I learned R in school and I've been
using it for all these projects up to
this point I'm going to use this
opportunity to Learn Python and so the
first time I did that and actually
applied it to a project it was a little
rough but as they say the rest is
history So eventually due to some of the
financial challenges of the company
among other things after about 3 years I
decided that it was time for me to move
on so I found another smallish company
that was also located in the Detroit
area which was where I lived at the time
now this wasn't a consulting company at
least in the traditional sense so the
company works in the Life Sciences
industry and the company functions as a
datadriven clinical research
organization And to clarify what I mean
by
smallish there were about 500 people for
a global headcount which is small in the
grand scheme of things but it was about
10x larger than the company that I had
just come from now how I got hired at
this company is actually a pretty
interesting story in its own right so
what had happened was I applied to a
senior manager position that I was
totally underqualified for at the time I
knew I was underqualified but I I
thought why not let's at least give it a
shot and see what happens needless to
say I didn't get a senior manager gig
but the people that I interviewed with
really liked me and it just so happened
a couple weeks later that the company
got this contract with one of the
largest pharmaceutical companies in the
world and the contract called for a
full-time rshiny developer now actually
R shiny was something that I had picked
up at my first job and I ended up trying
to get really good at it in my free time
the reason being I just found all these
use cases where I figured it could be
really helpful for taking our products
to the next level and before you knew it
because I had this skill it led to
another door opening so there's really
two takeaways from all of this number
one don't rule out a job just because
you appear to be somewhat underqualified
for it because you just never know
what's going to happen and then number
two grow your skills as much as possible
especially early in your career the more
skill you have just the more options
that are going to be available to you so
I spent one full year as an R shiny
developer now that may or may not sound
boring but it was actually a pretty
significant time for me R shiny can
force you to think in pretty
sophisticated ways about the r
programming language and even beyond
that you really have to put a lot of
thought into how to design apps that are
easy to use aesthetically pleasing and
ultimately useful for some end user plus
while I was doing some of this on the
side I was doing some other things for
my organization like building data
science processes and also helping to
vet the Julia programming language
that's where I came to learn about that
and what inspired my videos on that
topic now that large contract as an R
shiny developer was eventually scaled
back due to the pandemic so that had
just begun to take off and it was just
over one year of sitting in that
position I kept going with this company
for about a year after that
but then it was actually the inspiration
for another video I did before about why
I quit my data science job and the main
reason for that was although I love the
people there I found myself stagnating a
little bit and not growing in all the
areas that I wanted to be growing in I
was already senior level at the time but
I actually wanted to take a step back
and the reason for that was I just
wanted to have people around me and
above me that I could learn from and
just sort of absorb new information from
so I went through a pretty rigorous
interview process and I eventually
landed a position at an adte company
where that position was going to be
fully remote and interestingly in terms
of size and scale this company was
another 10-fold increase my first
company was about 50 people my second
company was about 500 people and this
company was about 5,000 people but then
also at the time I had already been
planning my move to Nashville that was
something that I talked about about in
my recent Life Update video and because
it was sort of at the tail end of the
pandemic when the Great resignation
period was going on so remote jobs were
taking off everywhere and I really
wanted a remote job just to support the
lifestyle that I planed to go into for
the next year now this company had a
tech stack that was completely different
from anywhere that I'd been in the past
to kind of put this into perspective my
first company it was a sequel and Python
and Rix for me then the second company
it was kind of a mixture of R and Julia
and then in this company it was all
Python and Spark so let's unpack that a
little bit the environment there
probably about 90% of the time or more
utiliz Jupiter notebooks where the code
in them was written in Python now I
could spend an entire video talking
about my opinions on that setup but
that's a separate topic for another day
but also they utilized a big data
framework known as HD FS or that is the
Hadoop distributed file system and the
data would get accessed by queering it
using the py spark API in practice what
that means is writing some Apache spark
code using py spark in Jupiter notebooks
so transforming it a little bit in a
sequel like fashion and then letting
standard python packages like numai and
pandas and psychic learn take over after
that point now python wasn't new to me
at At All by that time but spark and
hdfs and really the entire way that the
business operated was totally new to me
so there's definitely a learning curve
for me there but that was fine cuz
that's exactly why I wanted to be there
in the first place that was also where I
first got to experience data with counts
of rows in the billions so that's nice
so I ended up only staying at that
position for a little over a year and
there are a few reasons for that first
and foremost was I found that I just
wasn't super passionate about the adtech
space it was interesting sure but I
found I was just missing that passion
and that fire that was inside of me that
I knew existed when I was working on
Health Care problems and another big
personal thing for me was I was living
in a big brand new city at the time and
I was starting to feel a little lonely
and alienated just working in a remote
position where all of my co-workers
lived in a different state I had thought
at the time that a remote position was
what I wanted but I found eventually
that I just sort of preferred a hybrid
or an office setup that was somewhat
close to home so then that brings me to
my current position so a more detailed
walkthr of exactly what my day-to-day
looks like is the subject for another
video but I'll share some highle details
I work at I believe the single largest
employer in the Nashville area and I'm
back in the healthc care space and in
terms of the size and scale of the
company it's more than a 10x increase
from my last company matter of fact the
headcount at the company might be all
the way up to
300,000 and it's also easily the most
challenging job that I've ever had and
the single biggest reason for that is
the sheer size and complexity of the
data I learned from my first job in
healthcare sometimes the hard way that
really understanding the underlying
business processes that generate data is
critically important and there's tons of
reasons for that for one without that
knowledge you're not going to understand
things like what certain features mean
why some data is missing is it missing
at random or is it missing for some kind
of Reason uh what various categories
mean all kinds of other things and
without that knowledge it's really easy
to just kind of spin your wheels
endlessly working on something that you
think is useful and then you come to
find out later that it has no practical
value whatsoever to your
stakeholders well this is all doubly and
trip true as the size and complexity of
data increases in terms of the text
stack here it's primarily python based
but there is some SQL sprinkled in there
and the Google Cloud platform or gcp is
used as key infrastructure and I have a
whole video about getting the gcp
machine learning engineer certification
but long and short of it there's tons of
features and resources to learn in the
gcp environment M and it's definitely
significantly different from querying
data from hdfs but it's all instances of
upscaling and my focus last year and to
a certain extent this year too is around
just growing my skills in things like
mlops deploying applications to
production containerization test driven
development that kind of space so yeah
that's been the story of all my
different jobs so there's some summary
takeaway points that I want to conclude
with
first of all there's a caveat here that
all of this job history is prior to the
age of cat GPT and llms when I landed my
most recent position it was actually the
same month that open AI released chat
GPT to the public so that's definitely
going to change the landscape of jobs
out there going forward secondly
something I've tried to emphasize is
that no two Tech Stacks have been even
remotely the same in some places it's
been cloud-based in some places it's on
prank
in some places there's a hard python
requirement some places it's flexible
and some places everyone uses script and
some places everyone uses notebooks but
finally and this is probably the most
important point the most challenging
thing to me at every position and
especially at transitioning from one
position to another is learning the
company's business processes and just
understanding the data more so every
business and their clients have their
own process CES based on how they
operate their business and what they do
and generating data is Downstream from
that and you can't really move the
needle very much until you're an expert
at the underlying business and data and
that's hard honestly I've been in my
current position for a little over a
year now and I'm still every single week
just learning new things about the data
that I didn't know a week before now in
previous companies there had always been
a sort of a ramp up of let's say 3
months month or 6 months maybe up to a
year before I could reach my maximum
productivity just because there's all
that understanding and learning about
the domain that I needed to do first and
there's not many guarantees in the data
science world but that's as close to a
guarantee as it gets you are going to
have to dig a lot of your time into
understanding data and then eventually
learning how to clean it and manipulate
it but that's fine you'll learn a lot in
the process and the amount of skills
that you'll have and by extension of
that hopefully the amount of money that
you earn will go up overall I've
probably worked at more companies than
average for someone who's been out of
school for the length of time that I
have but I've learned so much along the
way that I really wouldn't have it any
other way so I hope this has been a
helpful and interesting video If you
enjoyed it smash the like button if you
hated it then I guess you're free to hit
the dislike button as well leave me a
comment down below and let me know have
you had multiple data science jobs
before
and if so what was your experience were
they really similar were they really
different let me know in the comments
down below then I'll see you all in the
not so distant future until then Richard
on data